didn't even French Canadian son of a gun
this trailer looks absolutely gorgeous
and as a fan of Dune I'm excited to dig
into all the hidden details this new
trailer has to offer if you're new to my
channel I've covered everything from the
1984 Dune the Children of Dune
miniseries starring James McAvoy and
vilnews dune part 1 which I'll leave
links to in the description if you want
to brush up but for now let's get right
into the deep dive of part 2 and be
warned there will be minor Dune spoilers
our first shot is of Paula tradies and
Cheney silhouetted against the dunes of
Iraqis his Homeworld of Caledon which we
saw briefly in part one is filled with
waves of water and Cheney who's never
set foot off Planet can't imagine a
world filled with something her world
has so little of later on in the trailer
we'll see the two kiss atop the same
Dune hinting at their romantic
relationship so when Paul says his first
line it's breathtaking it could also be
a reference to Cheney herself one of
those old romantic tropes then next shot
I absolutely love here we see Paul's
mother lady Jessica Atreides inside this
sort of cocoon and there's a lot to take
in here with Jessica having been taken
in by stilgar's fremin at the end of
part one it's likely these are Freeman
carrying her like royalty during a
sandstorm we'll see her adorned in a
sort of crown with markings on her face
and those iconic blue eyes something she
didn't have at the end of part 1. now in
the book this was the result of a ritual
called The Water of Life The Water of
Life is a poisonous substance extracted
from the sand worms of arrakis and used
to test a reverend mother's ability to
withstand its effects and access
ancestral memories of the benad jester
at Sisterhood we'll see a brief shot of
this water later on as a brief reminder
the benederate is a powerful all-female
organization whose main goal is to
manipulate Bloodlines in order to
produce the quitsats hadaraka being
believed to be the key to unlocking the
full potential of human evolution and
guiding Humanity to a new level of
awareness the benad Jesuit prophecy
states that the quitsat's hadarak will
come from a benad Jesuit and male line
of the Atreides family so if we go back
to this image it looks as though Jessica
has survived the Water of Life ritual
and proven herself to the foramen to
have tremendous Powers I also just love
whatever material is protecting this
kind of shell here almost as if it's the
shed lining from a snake or other
arrakis creature and now our first image
of Princess Ireland played by Florence
Pew the princess here is the daughter of
Emperor shaddam IV who we did not see in
part 1 nor in this trailer but he's
going to be played by oscar-winning
actor Christopher Walken she talks into
this voice recorder talking about the
secrets of Dune Ireland is a benad
jesurat herself and would be interested
in these secrets after all her father
the emperor forged a secret alliance
with a hearkenin to destroy house
Atreides and maintain power control over
the planet and thus the universe arakis
has the valuable resource known as
advice essential for space travel and
creating profound effects on human
consciousness whoever controls this
spice wields incredible power I love
this shot of a harken and Soldier
torching a mountain of atreidy's corpses
I even enjoyed the Added Touch of a
motor on the back of the helmet
suggesting some sort of cooling or
breathing mechanism a portrait of ducato
at tradies Burns in the fire suggesting
this is the hearkenings clearing
everything up from their Victorious
battle taking over the city of arakim
Jessica prior to her transformation
talks to Paul about how his father
didn't believe in revenge and revenge is
ultimately what Spurs Paul on his quest
he wants revenge on the hearkenings and
the emperor for killing his father even
if it goes against what his father would
have wanted we get this mysterious shot
of a silhouetted cloaked figure among a
rocky foreground we really don't know
who this is but considering the next
shot is of the princess pondering what
would happen if Paul were still alive I
place my bet on this being Paul and near
the end of the trailer we also see a
cloaked Paul atop a cliff now remember
in part one glossu Robin harkinen told
his uncle the baron harkenin that they
had chased Paul and Jessica into a
coriolis storm with Winds of up to 800
kilometers an hour there's no way anyone
could have survived so the hearkenin and
Emperor believe Paul to be dead we only
get a brief glimpse of a tall figure
beside the princess here and I wonder if
this could be Christopher Walken walking
beside her oh God and here we have
Gurney halleck one of Paul's instructors
who at the end of part 1 became a
fugitive On The Run he seems to be
wearing the same house at tradie's Armor
but it's definitely a bit worse for wear
bet on him linking up with Paul in their
battle against the hearken now this I
absolutely love it's our first shot of
Elvis as fade route the harkinen that's
Austin Butler of course and it looks as
though he's ready for some sort of
gladiatorial battle and you can make out
two daggers silhouetted on the ground
remember that Robin was in charge of
rooting out Paul so it's entirely
possible that the the baron finds out
Paul is still alive punishes Robin here
and calls for the even more ruthless
fade router to come to arrakis and
finish the job here we have Johnny and
Paul dodging some gunfire before we get
our first look at lady Margot played by
Leia sedu lady Margot was once a
resident of Iraqis having been married
to hasimir fenring the interim governor
of the planet during the transition of
power between hearken and Atreides she
is a benad Jesuit and acts as a sort of
spy who tried to warn lady Jessica of
the hearken and plot to kill Duke
Atreides we'll see her later on in black
and white suggesting this is either a
flashback and or the color scheme vilnuv
has chosen to go with when events take
place on the hearken and Homeworld of
gidi prime this seems to be some sort of
passcode to get into this chamber with
the imagery reminding me a lot of that
pain box Paul had to endure in part one
here Paul takes on two hearkening
soldiers which is contrasted with more
footage of fade router's Arena Battle
we'll see this battle with daggers for
shadowing invades dagger fight with Paul
at the end of the trailer it's implied
here that lady Margot watches this
battle from the stands adjusting the two
have some sort of History this shot
noticed that it's in color suggests fade
links up with Margot on arrakis it
almost looks as if he's going in for a
kiss but my guess is that he's trying to
figure out if Margot is a traitor this
shot of Lady Jessica with blue eyes
feels as though this is the first time
we see her after she survived the ritual
of water the largest portion of the
trailer focuses on Paul's first worm
ride where he puts down a thumper to
attract the Beast and successfully mount
it this is extremely important for Paul
as it earns him the respect of his
fremin allies and worms will be vital in
the overthrow of the ruling Powers
stillgar essentially tells him not to
show off but in true Paul fashion he
crushes this task uses these hooks to
gain control as the fremin cheer him on
but I love the look of disbelief on
stilgar's face almost as if he's coming
to the realization that Paul is the
quitsats atarak the one that will lead
the frame into Victory against their
oppressors here are a bunch of
ornithopters we saw from part one but
just where exactly they're headed or
who's controlling them we can't be sure
we can't really make out who's behind
this costume here it could be lady
Jessica and some benef behind her or it
could be someone involved in the Water
of Life ritual this woman is surrounded
by Harkin and soldiers judging from the
credits this appears to be actress
sahela yakub who plays shishokly a
foramen leader now these birds are
interesting and might be an example of
dis-trans animals animals used by the
fremant to send covert Communications so
them being dead makes sense as the
hearkenin would want to kill them before
they went off now if you're looking to
fight off werewolves here's princess
Ireland covered in this silver headdress
which almost looks like armor a brief
shot of arrakis's son cannabis
silhouetted by its two orbiting moons
here's Cheney going up a sand dune which
may be the same Dune she'll end up on
with Paul Jessica tells Paul that he
gave the fremin something to hope for
which is likely a reference to him being
the prophesized quitsats Hara something
the Freeman can get behind and give them
hope and Paul doesn't seem to take this
too well however the Final Shots show
him holding up his Chris knife a dagger
made from the tooth of a sand worm and
leading the Freeman before battle so it
would appear Paul has embraced this
prophecy and will lead his people to
Victory which of course leads him to a
one-on-one battle with fade arautha and
you can take a guess who ends up
Victorious he says the line made thy
knife chip and shatter which is an
actual line spoken by James in the books
and film May thy knife chip and shine
her I'm extremely stoked for part two it
looks like it's going to be even more
action-packed and filled with the insane
visuals and soundtrack we saw in part
one but now I want to hear from you what
are your thoughts and theories for part
two let me know in the comments below
thanks for watching make sure to like
And subscribe I'll be coming out with
even more Doom videos and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember
thank you